good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and
happy Friday Friday gotta get down on
Friday everybody's looking forward to
the weekend weekend Friday Friday
getting down on
Friday welcome everyone to the toast to
Friday to the end of the week we're
sliding into the weekend and the toast
your favorite shouting words podcast
we'll get you there I feel
good I know that
I it's Friday we have a gorgeous show
we're wearing our new merch life is good
you know woohoo in case you missed it
yesterday we have a merch drop coming up
Monday 10:00 a.m. eastern time the Wench
collection Claudia election Claudia is
now wearing the cream wench reindeer set
so gorgeous so sweet so cute and I am
wearing weny lights which is wench in
lights I'm so excited about this merch
drop I'm so excited that it's Friday
it's going to be a great show and I'm
even more excited because on yesterday
show I did like probably one of the most
annoying things a human being could do
and say like oh my God I have the
craziest thing to tell you the biggest
piece of gossip and
then I said wait no I can't say it was
embargoed but thankfully one of our
stories today is the news that leaked
that leaked and then Claudia will share
her perspective and what was there what
she would have said yesterday yes so
that's really exciting we can button
that up I know people were that I did
get a few texts like what is it did you
tell them yes said I'll call you later
then I forgot to call them that's so
turty that's so that's so
turty she won't tell
yeah oh Turtle oh it's just Friday like
I'm smileing I'm Smiley tury like it's
Friday it feels like a well-earned
Friday it was a very good busy
productive week and I'm just so excited
to ease into the weekend and next week
is a Ola day it's a Ola day it's
Thanksgiving oh my gosh I'm so excited
for next week just enter the Chill Zone
you know yeah so next week scheduling
update there are shows Monday and
Tuesday and then Wednesday Thursday
Friday we are offer Thanksgiving I'm
Overjoyed I can't wait I don't even like
Thanksgiving food but I love the
Thanksgiving VI
we have a lot I know that's like not
what you want to hear some people want
to show every day but we have good news
too the good news is that next week we
will have patreon episodes on the days
that we are out and today we have a new
patreon episode that just dropped
yesterday General Q&A with Jackson turd
where everyone just got to write
whatever questions they have for us and
we're answering them so many great
questions so many great conversations
we're going to do a part two because we
have 1 million more questions that are
pertinent to the situation so that will
be forthcoming next week week and next
week we are also doing our annual
patreon episode which is the fast five
stories that you need to know for the
Thanksgiving table so we're choosing
five like world news stories that people
are going to be talking about at
Thanksgiving we're going to break it
down for you as best as we can and then
we're also going to give you a hot take
to bring to the table so yeah start some
trouble that is one of our favorite
episodes to do and most productive yeah
know and also I find myself learning so
much during that episode because you
know I very much like to you know keep
to myself I like to just you know engage
with things that I Am Naturally inclined
to engage with and doing the Fast Five
Thanksgiving annual every year I learned
so much we were talking about this on
patreon how last year we finally like
read everything and learned and
understood everything about what was
going on with FTX yeah and everyone was
talking about it at the time and I had
no [__] clue what these people were
talking about and then we did the
episode and I really felt like a world
leader you I mean you are yeah and so we
will leave you after that episode
feeling like a world leader so like
Jackie said even though there's no
regular toast episodes next week if
you're desperate for an episode there
will be one on the days one every day on
the days that we are not in so that's
Wednesday Thursday and Friday next week
Monday we've got the merch drop today
we've got a gorgeous show I mean
Cate Good Times come
on let's
celebrate take your good times and your
bad
times going to have a party together
with you and
[Music]
celebrate and have a good time you're
doing a lot of singing for like being on
a show with a person who has kind of a
perfect voice right now it's Friday and
I can't help that the actual Joy I feel
over the fact that it's Friday is
emulating through my bones oh oh
oh bless you gazen is coming through me
and manifesting itself in song I I won't
apologize for that that
ever okay um did you finish fourth wi I
did finish fourth wi and I started iron
flame wow that's a fun thing to be able
to do to just jump from one to the next
what percent you're probably further
than me and iron flame no no no like
they just got back to basat they haven't
even like walks through the doors they
just landed got it yeah I'm 10 I was
reading all night last night I'm 10%
like what is going on no the book is
really long the book is really long and
like the writing
style is just
very you know she doesn't spare any
words like no they're all there every
word every thought there she used all of
them she used all of them so I I mean
it's still good and and I'm into it I'm
into it I'm into it um what else can I
tell you about myself before we dive in
well I could tell you that I'm
rearranging my spice cabinet I don't
know if you guys have seen but I have
bought I've bought uniform spice jars
and that is going to be my project this
weekend labeling I think it's for the
best like I'm not want to judge
obviously but you know your spice rack
was like kind of a dump how would you
know we made a brisket together and I
was in charge of spices that's true and
what does your spice rack look like I
mean I just had the organizers come so
like it looks pretty good do you have
uniform spice I
do bless you okay am I getting sick I'll
die you got you needed Norton's
antivirus what oh because my illness was
contagious um I do have a uniform spice
rack but I don't use it uh well I'm
going to be sifting spices all day today
which is very like I like that sort of
activity it's like mind numbing calming
as long as I can find the time to do it
but I think I I will so I'm really
excited about that and then I'm going to
cook a little dinner one pot dish
tonight what's for dinner it's like a
chicken
teriyaki bake oh that sounds [__]
good I I found the recipe on Instagram
from the wooden Skillet I'll send it to
you oh make Ben make it for you a
chicken teriyaki I don't care if it's
baked fried roasted grilled or shoved up
my vagina like I love chicken teriyaki
and then the veggies and the rice are
cooked in the one pot with the chicken
m yeah that's what I'm going for and is
the chicken like cut up is it breasts
it's thigh I know you don't love thigh
oh no but like thigh I don't know what
to do because I love a breast obviously
but like you don't get the juice with a
breast like why thigh no no no dish
ruined can you make it with white meat I
don't like dark meat on a on chicken or
like thigh the parts I could eat of it
which is like three bites cuz the rest
is like crazy three bites it's like Skin
and Bones maybe I could make a couple
thighs a couple breasts because you do
need the fat like chicken breasts have
no fat on them oh sorry I will not be
making this dish like a couple times
I've tried to replace like a a classic
dish in instead of using thighs and legs
I've used breasts mhm there's no flavor
I refuse choose to believe that because
I love Chen breast no remember when I
made you guys that World War II meal at
my house when my friends were here yes
and it turned out so poorly because I
only use chicken breast and not the rest
of the
chicken it just had no flavor just it
was World War II food because um the the
Flav were rationed um and it was like
meat and potatoes with no flavor I don't
care like no I was thinking of maybe
throwing a couple breasts into the pot
oh I got two if I got two if you need
but you know I don't like to deviate
from the recipe so I'm struggling I'm so
sorry for you I've been through a lot
chy I've been through a lot but that
won't stop you from spreading Joy today
never spreading holiday cheer you are
the cheer Meister I am I am
and
yeah all out of things to say yeah she's
speechless I ran out of compliments you
know that's okay it's true won't let my
personal stresses and issues affect the
show ever especially not this chicken
debacle no it's all going to work out
tury yeah so let me know how the OPD
turns out I will I love an OPD and
honestly I'm just like itching to get to
the stories so I can share my piece of
Gossip make it about you I understand my
God she's calling me out hard today no I
know talking about my spices was hard
but we did it we got through it no I
feel like I was extremely supportive no
and you were able to make it about you
because you had been in my spice cabinet
for the roast right right and I don't
think like let's just talk really
quickly I don't think like that's me
making everything about myself like
that's me being a part of your journey
do you know what I mean yeah no but I
think it's hard when I'm talking about
something that like you're not a part of
yeah no and I just think for like the
sake of the show like we should talk
about things that we're both a part of
you know oh okay I'll make sure to hold
everything to that standard I think so
okay so without
further ad
yeah it's time for the fast five stories
that you need to know including tury's
bit of tea and the fast five stories
that you need to know are brought to you
by betterhelp thank you betterhelp for
sponsoring today's episode this time of
year can be a lot and it feels very
natural to feel some sadness or anxiety
about it but adding something new and
positive to your life can counteract
some of those feelings therapy can be a
bright spot amid all of those stresses
and changes something to look forward to
to make you feel grounded and to give
you the tools to manage everything
that's going on like once I know that
the traffic in New York is starting to
get bad like I know holiday season is
officially here and holiday season for a
lot of people can be very isolating can
be very sad you can miss you know people
who have passed you can feel sad for a
multitude of reasons and it's totally
normal and therapy is just a great way
to balance those feelings and better
help is just a fabulous resource because
if you're thinking of starting therapy I
really recommend giving better help a
try it's done entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule you just fill
out a brief questionnaire you get match
with a licensed therapist and you can
switch therapists any time for no
addition additional charge one of the
you know annoying things about therapy
is like the social awkwardness of it
sometimes you get you meet a therapist
and it's just like not a good vibe and
it's very natural for you not to like
your first your second or even your
third therapist eventually you find
someone but it could be so awkward like
calling canceling the waiting room it's
just painful better help takes all of
that away better help is done entirely
online you can just like communicate
with your therapist in any mode that you
feel comfortable with so you can talk to
them on the phone you can video chat
with them you can even text with them
and it's just really accessible and
really convenient I think a lot more
venient than inperson therapy um and if
you need to switch therapist it's not a
big deal find your bright spot this
season with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com toast today to get 10%
off your first month that's better
hp.com toast today's episode is also
brought to you by kit Kit's biggest fans
are saying that their time-saving beauty
Essentials for Hair Skin and Body are
gamechanging so are you ready to up your
beauty game CH whatever your budget
whatever your skin type or your hair
type kit believes that you deserve
little indulgences at affordable prices
morning noon and at night so maybe
you've seen Kit's satin pillowcases
their caps and eye masks they're great
for your hair and skin while you sleep
or maybe you've seen their heatless
satin curling rollers where you can say
goodbye to heat damage I love kit
products satin scrunchie hello I have a
satin eye mask too I use um oh I love
their claw Clips they also have great
bottle free Beauty so shampoo and
conditioner bars if you're wanting to
like reduce waste but still have
Gorgeous Hair they have bars they look
like soap but it's shampoo and
conditioner no bottles they last really
long and they smell amazing plus right
now for a limited time they have a
Barbie collab you can live the Barbie
dream life with the Barbie by kit
collection featuring Kit's best-selling
satin pillow cases in an iconic Barbie
pink um super cute all of the items are
like really goodlook you know so they're
like hair accessories that are stunning
but they work really well they're made
really well people love it I love those
heatless satin curling rollers you sleep
with them in your hair you don't have to
curl your hair or blow dry your hair
it's fabulous right now kit is offering
you 30% off your entire order at my
kit.com toast that's right 30% off any
anything and everything at myit kits
c.com toast one more time it's my
kit.com toast for 30% off your entire
order I also feel like kit is great for
a secret santa because it's like a cute
small thing for like a girly girl in
your life did you get oh I didn't do it
yet no I'm done yeah but I know I we're
doing a family secret santa um on our
vacation this year I got I know who I'm
getting okay but I wanted to ask you
like are you and Zach telling each other
who yes because you are who the other
got oh my God me and Ben didn't I don't
think you should be allowed oh but I I
want to help him but what if he got you
or you got him oh well um then that
would suck oh man me and Ben didn't
share oh wow cuz there are some I heard
I don't know which generator we did for
secret santa but there are some
generators that's what we okay but there
are some that will like you can make it
so certain people can't get each other
we didn't do that hopefully no one got
their
spouse um are you how are you feeling
about who you got I'm feeling good I'm
feeling good too I'm dying to know who
got me like not to be rude like I really
hope it's not one of the boys I just
feel like they're not serious about
right but that's why they tell their
wives and the wives help even though
Zach has I want to ask Olivia I really
don't think we should tell spouses I
mean it's over I already did but also
Zach told me what he was thinking of
about getting for his person he needed
no help like he's fine oh did you guys
tell each other who you got for secret
santa question mark
me and Ben took a vow of silence period
but Jackie and Zach shared I wouldn't
have been able to I need to know who he
got good thing he didn't get
me right and good thing you didn't get
him yeah good thing but yes I got I got
someone good I mean I don't think
there's anyone bad
like but I got someone good yeah you
know what there really is no one bad CU
it's not about like the person or how
you feel about them it's like if they're
able to receive a good gift you know
like if they have a personality I could
think of something to get for everyone
me too it's very exciting we've never
done a secret santa before I'm excited
I'm really excited too I need to start
googling yeah okay well our first story
is tury's bit of Team okay so Jewish
Stars Amy Schumer Deborah Messing and
Sasha Baron Cohen among other
celebrities and influencers such as
Claudia ashre slam Tik Tok for allowing
anti-Semitism to be Rife across the
platform including by the way we don't
need to read the article let me tell you
what happened okay okay well the New
York Times wrote up this thing that tury
was trying was wanting to tell every and
then it was everywhere so now that
somebody else snitched I'm going to I'm
going to share my truth and this is what
I was going to say yesterday last night
at or two nights ago now at 6 o'clock I
had been invited to join a zoom call
where you know apparently some big
people at Tik Tok were going to be
listening to Jewish celebrities and
creators talk about their experience on
the app thus far and like why the
situation is so dire and it started out
you know very nicely and you know of
course of course me I'm like nosy there
was only like 15 celeb SES influencers
so I was like looking at everyone and
everybody had their cameras on like
let's say I saw Mrs Amy Schumer's living
room I was like that's a gorgeous room
and there was somebody with their box
turned off and I was like I wonder who
that is and the Master of Ceremonies the
the way that the call was supposed to go
was we'd hear from Tik Tok you know they
were saying they take this very
seriously yada y yada and then they
wanted to hear from some of the biggest
creators I'm not going to name anyone
because I don't want to like put their
you know whatever but people gave really
powerful testimonies about how [__]
horrible this last month has been for
them people ranging from like ages 16 to
30 I heard stories about you know
people's families getting doxed I heard
stories about you know Orthodox creators
having gotten doxed their address being
sent out everywhere and receiving 10
deliveries a day of like pork into their
home like horrible horrible things and
we all just were like listening to
everybody's um testimonies and then if
you had something to say you just wrote
in the chat and I raised my hand and
somebody else raised their hand at the
same time somebody with their camera
turned off and so the the leader of the
call this guy from Tik Tok was like all
right let's go to the chat let's go to
the person's username was
SBC and so when you raise your hand you
got brought to the top so everybody
could see you so it was me in this blank
box not to make everything about me no
literally how you're centering yourself
in this story and so SBC turns his
camera on it's Sasha Baron Cohen I had
no idea who was going to be on this call
and and he he's the type of person who
has immense power and you know Tik Tok
doesn't affect his you know business so
all the people on the call this far who
get you know most of their livelihood
from Tik Tok they were being extremely
respectful they're not trying to you
know make themselves a Target or piss
off people at Tik Tok they were just
being respectful and just trying to
convey you know their sadness in an
attempt to make a change at Tik Tok and
Sasha Baron Cohen is not in the same
bucket as most of the people and he
just
annihilated you guys I could not stop
laughing like he was speaking [__]
truths and he was just basically saying
I understand why up until this point
everybody on this call has been
immensely respectful but like I don't
give a [__] I know how these things work
he has an organization that like does
things like this and he's like I've
spoken to Mark Zuckerberg I've spoken to
everyone important in every country in
every tech company in the world I know
that the issue that's going on on Tik
Tok right now spreading misinformation
boosting anti ISM I know that is fixed
with the click of a button I know it's
one thing and I know that you're not
doing it so you can say the guy from Tik
Tok was like oh we're trying to do
better he was like that's [__] he
said [__] that's [__] and then
he asked the people from Tik Tok like
what's your job what is your job here
and it was like you know these fancy
titles and he was like why isn't the CEO
here like this is you're not taking this
seriously you're doing this to appease
people you're doing this for public
perception you have blood on your hands
this is the worst anti-semitic
propaganda movement since the Nazis
spitting facts so hard and he was like
talking then he turned his attention to
all the creators being like there is
power in you protesting Tik Tok like
stop posting on there tell all your big
friends to stop posting on there I know
it's your livelihood I know it is and I
have empathy for that but there is power
in stopping promoting these types of
apps he just went on and on everybody's
stunned and then he just hangs up
King oh my God it was the most like
baller move I've ever seen in my life
you know like he there were no niceties
mhm there were no um you know Hi how are
you he came he set his peace and he
left obsessed I mean it's so true Tik
Tok has been a problem for a while and a
lot of different capacities in ways big
and small it's affecting you know kids
me there's the mental health
conversation there's all these different
things about Tik Tok but what we're
seeing now I mean literally a letter to
Osama it's yeah Beyond The Pale like it
and by the way this was before the Osama
letter so we had this call and then the
next morning Osama Bin Laden is trending
on Tik Tok like it couldn't have been
more poetic I watched some of those
videos of I just read letter to Osama
and I'll never look at the world the
same again and like I'll never look at
you the same it it was so crazy to watch
and it was like there's so many videos
they also all kind of uh like parot the
same language the way that these people
speak and they
also try to sound like
so
smart and educated and like scholarly
scholarly but it's it's it it's really
really dark but anyways Tik Tok is a big
problem I mean it's been a national
security issue for a while now it's an
actual security issue and something has
to be done but they're the whoever you
guys were on a call with like they they
don't have the power they don't have the
power like this is the a Chinese app
they are happy to poison this country
with this app like it's it's it's going
how they want it to go yeah no so it was
like a fruitless call and I think
everybody knew that but you know what
were we going to do say no no of course
and I'm like I I don't know if someone
was supposed to snitch or not but I'm
glad that it's making headlines yeah no
me too I'm so glad because now I can
speak my truth and I wasn't the snitch
and Sasha Baron Cohen is like a major
voice yes and I think his voice is also
made more potent by the fact that he
doesn't use it all the time for
everything no he's not like a big
speaker outer not a big speak but when
he speaks you listen yeah he's also
extremely smart yeah and funny and like
well respected in his field um and it
was just honestly like so crazy I've
actually met him once before at a party
and he was so incredibly nice him and
Isa um but seeing him in this we're so
used to seeing him you know
Aladin seeing him so serious and so
poignant and so well spoken and so
powerful I was like damn
Daddy yeah no that's that's wild I'm
glad you could share it was a crazy
thing to be a part of let me tell you
I'm glad you could share your experience
who invited you
um who did invite
me like the or maybe it was I don't know
I've been like everybody keeps asking me
to like sign these letters I'm just's
like yeah yes put my name yeah so I'm
not sure I think it was maybe Aon but
I'm not sure um and you know who's an
unpr problematic Queen who's been
boycotting Tik Tok for a while now
you
me yeah me
yeah me you guys get the [__] off Tik
Tok for real but like I can't tury no I
know I know I know I know like and it's
not even issue for you no offense like
it it's not like wow wow it's never been
like your
place yeah but it does feel like one of
those things that's so big like what
impact will me leaving have you know
except robbing people of the Joy Sasha
said you have an impact Sasha said but
Sasha didn't know I have like no
followers on that up but if it's like if
it's a lot of little people like that
matters yeah and you shouldn't be you
shouldn't have to see the things that
you guys are seeing there in your
comments and also like in your for you
like these videos yeah no and that's
what people were sharing like not only
is the misinformation such a problem on
the app they have no way to monitor like
you know propaganda sharing photos you
know that aren't actually from this year
and you know people claiming that
they're from yesterday but the absolute
vitriol that gets thrown the way of
Jewish creators and there are no tools
for creators to protect themselves or
protect their mental health like you can
the really one tool that Instagram uses
you like you can block words so like
people have literally they were sharing
like I've been blocking the word an
Frank because people just say Anne Frank
and be like [__] Anne Frank or Hitler
was right you can block phrases is and
that tool barely even works cuz that
people will just be like Hitler with two
RS you know right or exclamation for the
ey so there was talk about like
different tools that they
could Implement to protect creators but
that doesn't even solve the larger issue
it's just protecting creators and um
wait there was another thing oh and you
know they shared that you know in the
wake of October 7th 24 million new fake
accounts were
made 24 million I don't know if that was
the day after the weeks but and I'm sure
a lot of fake accounts get made every
day but that was like an insane Spike
that is so interesting mhm yeah there's
a lot of Bot farming going on too right
now yes for sure part of like the the
war that's being waged on the internet
on social media yeah totally it's a
front of the war yeah
1,000% so it was just a very interesting
moment that took a turn I was not
expecting wow well
I love Tasha like come over for Shabbat
I love you yeah I wonder what's going to
happen with Tik Tok honestly I you know
like a year ago or months ago there's
always this conversation that comes up
about like you know on a federal level
like Banning Tik Tok because it's like
bad for National Security right they did
say on the call like at the beginning
before anybody spoke he you know the
thing about China and he was like I can
assure you that's not
true how is Chinese Chinese interests
aren't being funnel that's what he said
but like how and why would that not be
true right right it's a Chinese owned
app right like why wouldn't they use it
to serve whatever ends they want it to
serve they wanted to serve and then it
reminds me of that thing I saw in 60
minutes that really stuck with me about
Tik Tok how of course you know they have
it in China because it's a Chinese app
but they use it so differently in China
because it's targeted towards youth but
all of the content is educational so you
can scroll for x amount of time but
you're watching videos about science
about engineering about math about
history like you're you're in but you're
learning no you're not watching people
slap each other in the face with a
tortilla right and then when you compare
it to the content on American Tik Tok
which is moronic yeah it's it does feel
like M this feels like a a tool right
but it's like I right now miss the
moronic use of Tik Tok because now it's
being used in really damaging harmful
ways but even but like but it's been
it's been bad for years
so I don't know what will be
me neither very interesting our next
story is also crazy what is it Diddy is
the subject of a NYPD criminal
investigation apparently and it involves
a sexual assault so Diddy is the subject
of a secret NYPD investigation and
although it's unclear if his ex Cassie
made the criminal complaint there is
strong evidence it involves sexual
assault law enforcement sources tell TMZ
there's an open case with the Mi at the
NPD with the name Sean Colmes we're told
it is an active case but the case file
has been locked essentially meaning it's
a sensitive case where access is
restricted as TMZ reported Cassie has
followed an explosive Federal lawsuit
which alleges rape and human trafficking
among other accusations that's insane
TMZ inquired about the case to the NPD
and the responded with this statement
the NYPD takes sexual assault and rape
cases extremely seriously and urges
anyone who has been a victim to file a
police report so we could perform a
comprehensive
investigation uh it would seem based on
the stat nothing it would seem also that
not only is this a sexual assault case
but the NYPD is actively looking for
other alleged
victims right so they're there's like
they're not giving us much yeah but we
know that there is an investigation and
damn like an investigation and a lawsuit
filed by Cassie also in this lawsuit she
accuses Diddy of blowing up kid C's Car
in um in 2012 so did he allegedly blew
up kid C's Car after he discovered kid
Cy was wooing his former girlf Cassie
while they were on a break in the
shocking abuse lawsuit that Cassie filed
against Diddy she claims the rapper
became so enraged about her new Ro
romance that he warned her around the
time of Paris Wasing week in 2012 that
he would blow up cu's car around that
time kid C's car exploded in his
driveway oh my God this is like a movie
yeah no this is seriously crazy the
allegation human trafficking human
so I mean it could mean any number of
things but it could also you know
passing her around oh my God oh my God
no yeah it's very limited what we know
but like the allegations are extremely
severe yeah and then also I saw this
morning that someone else is now coming
forward um his other ex once claimed
that he stomped on her stomach and
dragged her by his hair so this is his
ex Gina claimed that the rapper stomped
on her stomach punched her in the head
during their five-year relationship she
goes by the uh nicknam Virginia V she
leveled the allegations in a 2019
interview and that has resurfaced in
light of Cassie's bombshell lawsuit
against Diddy I imagine for Cassie to
have launched an investigation and the
lawsuit she's probably been keeping a
record for a very long time because he's
just a very powerful person and I think
people make allegations and probably
most of them are true against powerful
people and they don't stick unless
unless you have years and
years like things that the you know the
public and the police Can't Ignore yeah
um and some of the other details from
the lawsuit that she filed where she
accused him of rape and repeated
physical abuse um she said that she met
him in 2005 when she was only 19 he
allegedly began a pattern of abuse and
control that included allegedly forcing
her to have sex with male prostitutes
while he filmed physically abusing her
and supplying her with drugs she also
alleged that he forced his way into her
home home and raped her towards the end
of their longtime relationship in
2018 holy [__] like every manner of
awful of hor horror abuse oh [__] this
man yeah ew like gross hate for Life
yeah hate for Life canel cancelled
actually
canceled you would hope yeah I know it's
like when someone's so powerful like
he's really such a purveyor of culture
and he's been famous for so many years
like it's very difficult to like this is
a person when we talk about cancel
culture like this is who should be
canceled this is a criminal like a very
violent criminal and it's like you know
Harvey Weinstein esque in the sense like
you think this person has so much power
they can be taken down right but it
takes like it takes everyone yeah
collectively and Harvey Weinstein you
know was
uh there were criminal charges against
him so he literally was canceled cuz
he's going to jail you know in I don't
even know so so there's the lawsuit of
her vers him but there is also the NYPD
criminal investigation and they are
looking for other victims it seems I
pray for Swift Justice yeah I'm so
sorry that this girl who was
19 had to endure
this Terri terrible story yeah terrible
terrible story and such graphic
allegations you know yeah and I mean
there's even more in the lawsuit oh I'm
sure that and I'm sure because sensitive
it's sealed there's that yeah there's
the sealed case but then also the
lawsuit like that just scratches the
surface there's a number of incidents
that it's incredibly Brave incredibly
Brave yeah to do this this is a person
who is so well connected who's so
powerful who's so wealthy yeah and has
been for 20 years like that's in like
that's insane power like that those are
that's like an immovable Force yeah very
very brave
and [__] him Swift Justice yeah our next
story Switching gears a little please
Ariana Grande supports her boyfriend
Ethan Slater at the opening night of his
musical spam a lot no and he was filmed
out of by TMZ yesterday leaving the
courthouse like for his divorce
proceedings yeah like it's too much it's
too much Ariana Grande was spotted
supporting her boyfriend former
SpongeBob Ethan Slater for the opening
night of musical she was photographed
did you say former SpongeBob yeah
because he played SpongeBob on Broadway
yep where's the lie no there is not a
lie I was just wanting to make sure I
heard you right the song sh was
photographed unless it's like once
you're a SpongeBob you're always a
SpongeBob once a bob always a bob like
kind of like being an Olympian like
you're not a former Olympian you're
always an Olympian right it's a good
question I guess we'd have to ask the
Bob himself sound off in the comments
once a SpongeBob always a SpongeBob
title title title title title
alert the song just his photograph
getting out of an SUV as she arrived to
watch spam a lot on Broadway Thursday
spam a
lot you know me she's British now oh the
crown is out so exciting but is it the
whole season Netflix doesn't do that to
us except for love BL Love is Blind yeah
um I don't know you just threw me off
sorry sorry she glammed up for the
occasion sporting a black strapless
velvet dress Shear gloves and pearl
earrings she wore her blonde hair up in
a ponytail with a bright lead lip yeah
she looked gorgeous um that's not the
story no no no it's not I saw a lot of
pictures like people sneaking pictures
of her inside the theater very
supportive I guess in a way I'm glad
they're still together like if you're
going to blow up his life like at least
let it be for something you know yeah I
guess she's ready to take her
relationship out on the town they
started dating in July and it's November
okay so I just I feel like we need to
keep a time like keep that in mind so
they've been dating you know probably 6
months at this point yeah and Ari
doesn't care no and I know we talked
about this story like at length when it
when it dropped but did we make note of
Ariana Grande having the worst tast in
men like no like even the guy she
married like who right I didn't think he
was that cute yeah big she she had a
uh eye when she was dating Big Sean she
yeah and then she I feel like they're
kind of OTP even though I know he's like
literally in a 10-year relationship and
they're very happy and then she was with
Ricky whoever that is right wasc Ricky
she he was the one who encouraged her to
lick the donuts I was like her Bad Gal
era so that's a bad guy right now I
listen and laugh he Davidson is not a
bad guy no I don't like I I was talking
more like looks I don't think he's that
great and MC Miller is not a bad guy but
I just just feel
like the crop of men and now this one
I'm like you're the biggest star in the
world like pull a Taylor Swift like do a
flip with Travis Kelce you know H Taylor
Swift I hope Taylor's inspiring people
to like just go for the obvious choice
like shoot for the moon who's sexiest
man alive him by the way it's so funny
cuz like when a really handsome guy like
dates the most obvious looking like girl
who's just like a model honestly it
bothers me I'm like just do do something
crazy like date a chubby girl you know
but when a girl does it I love it like
go for the hottest thing you can find in
your life no but even if Ari was just
eating a male model like that that
wouldn't do it for
me it would be better like unless it was
like you know the biggest model like
that I've heard of yeah but you couldn't
even name one who's the biggest male
model I cannot name one who's just a
model by trade who doesn't act or
sing who's a male model I haven't know a
male model since I watched Athan ocean
amazing reference I know I mean that
most famous there was that guy for many
years who was like Ralph Lauren nacho oh
and then there's that guy from the
Kardashians
365 what or um that guy from he was on
the Kardashians in
Milan he's not a model he's an actor
Michelle Michelle yeah okay tell me if
you know any of these people Alton Mason
no Jordan Barrett no Tyson Beckford yes
that's familiar and let me know if you
know any of them or like maybe I Mark
vandero
no oh interesting Derek zoolander's name
is Loosely based on
vandero okay so he must have been a big
deal Lucky Blue Smith actually that name
sounds
familiar oh Zach Mo do you know him no
he made headlines in 2016 I remember
this story making him I am models and
the fashion industry's first plus-size
male model star he's very braw looking I
actually I remember that story is he
actually big like big is he actually
famous no no oh I thought you were
asking if he was actually fat no no is
he is he actually a big star no Braden
Hudson cronig no Armando Cal no okay
this is fruitless okay sha opri and I
only know him he's the the model in the
blank space music video okay okay so say
he's the biggest male model in the world
if Ari started dating him I would be
into
that
yeah I can't believe there's not like
one name that we're like missing you
know like classic oh
yeah I mean like David Beckham is on
this list that's not what I'm talking
about but all the PE all these list say
the same couple of people and I've never
heard of them we need to talk more about
that we need to talk more about that why
is it so hard for male models to break
out cuz I feel like male models when it
comes to like spreads and stuff like
they're just background like no but like
there are as many men's companies and
Brands as there are women's no for real
like why don't they become famous yeah
like
zenya Ralph Lauren anything yeah I feel
like there was an ERA where Ralph Lauren
had like a couple of um classic male
models Brook's Brothers Ral Lauren what
is that guy's name that everybody like
he I think he was in Gossip
Girl nacho yeah it's like the classic
guy but he says I'm not a model I'm a
polo
player so weird someone needs to look
into this somebody like somebody's goal
like somebody needs to become the
biggest male model of all time cuz I
could name a hundred female models right
now I could name a
thousand not from any generation there
was like the ' 80s and '90s the early
2000s like right now not one male botel
not one you think is the biggest model
in the world right
now Kendall probably still Kendall yeah
yeah yeah but I feel like she there's
we're due for like a it's I mean I think
it's Kaa Gerber but she's still a little
green yeah but I feel like there's we're
due for like a a new not generation
they're all the same generation but like
a new wave yeah no they're actually like
not all the same age like KY we're super
young no but not the same age but
they're still the same generation yeah
it's like eight years difference where's
like the 16-year-old Karly CLA who was
like at prom got discovered and the next
day went to the meala yeah we're due for
some fresh faces yeah and may the
industry May the industry protect them
may may the industry have learned what
was the story here are supporting Ethan
Slater oh okay yeah let's get back to
that um I'm not here for it I'm just
going to be negative on this one like
why I mean I don't think anybody's here
for it it's still a little soon honestly
I mean he's literally still in court for
his divorce I saw him yesterday leaving
the courthouse no like maybe when his
daughter goes to college he could start
dating and stepping out with his new
woman but until then no no it's hella
disrespectful it's too soon not for them
to be dating because they are obviously
dating it's too soon for them to be
rubbing everyone's face in it publicly
yeah I completely agree and I just maybe
I can't get behind this cuz like I don't
think they're a good couple and like I
don't like imagine they're the most in
love couple of all time I don't think
that they are I think it's so AR I think
she's just like very Whimsical she he's
like I'll leave my wife for you she's
like great and in a few months she might
change her mind like I think she's just
very flyed by the seed of her pants type
of
energy a little bit destructive you know
yeah if I had to
guess it's a it's a fair guess our next
story are you ready for it is it the
next story that's brought to you by
manscaped pance it is manscaped thank
you for sponsoring this episode Mary
balls Miss from our friends at manscaped
ladies the holidays are approaching and
what what if I told you that the perfect
GI gift does exist Santa's helpers have
been working hard to bring you manscapes
brand new performance package 5.0 Ultra
for the man in your life who doesn't
love the gift of smooth balls featuring
the new lawnmower 5.0 Ultra Ball trimmer
wa watch all his wishes and mistletoe
kisses come true the perfect mix of
naughty and nice go to manscape.com and
use code toast for 20% off in free
shipping manscaped performance package
5.0 is the ultimate bundle for the man
who deserves it all um we have the lawn
mower 5.0 the weed whacker 2.0 and the
ear and nose trimmer the manscaped
liquid formulations and two free gifts
so the lawnmower 5.0 is the fifth
generation Ben loves this um he uses it
on his face pretty much every day in the
beer trimmings get everywhere but that's
my problem it's a standard trimmer for
taking the little hair off the top it
has a foil blade for him to go that
smooth finish the lawn mower 5.0 body
trimmer and then also the weed whacker
nose and ear hair trimmer that's a gift
for you as well don't for forget the
gift doesn't stop there the bundle comes
with two free gifts a pair of manscaped
boxers and the shed 2.0 toiletry bag oh
I love that toiletry bag get 20% off in
free shipping with code toast at
manscape.com that's 20% off with free
shipping at manscaped.com when you use
code toast gift him manscaped and unwrap
your favorite present this year thank
you manscape for sponsoring today's
episode that's also another great one
for a secret santa if you want to keep
it under a certain amount there's a
bunch of guys in your Secret Santa and
you get a guy that's a good one today's
episod is also brought to you by
Squarespace Squarespace is the
all-in-one website platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online whether you're just starting out
or managing a growing brand Squarespace
makes it easy to create a beautiful
website engage with your audience and
sell anything from products to content
to time and you can do it all in one
place and all on your terms so whatever
reason you might be wanting for starting
a website Squarespace has a product
feature to support your website so you
can upload an asset Library you'll be
able to upload organize and access all
your content from one place with the new
asset library and you're able to manage
all your files from one Central Hub and
use them across Squarespace
squarespace's platform you can sell
custom merch on a Squarespace website
you can sell your products on an online
store they have flexible website
templates you can get started with one
of their professional website templates
with designs for every category and use
case and then customize your look update
your content and add features to it that
fit your unique needs they also have
email campaigns a fluid engine and a
point of sale so you can sell in person
by connecting a square Square Reader to
the Squarespace app and you'll be able
to keep your orders your inventory and
your customer data in sync all within
your online store so it's 2023 girl get
a website and don't make it janky make
it with Squarespace it'll look
professional it'll look like you paid
someone a lot of money to do it but our
little secret it was just you and
Squarespace so if you're a photographer
a videographer you want to create a
portfolio online if you're a graphic
designer Squarespace is great for that
if you have a side hustle you want to do
e-commerce Squarespace is also great for
that so head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com toast to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain that's
squarespace.com toast to save 10% off
your per first purchase of a website or
a domain thank you la you're welcome P
our next story yes fans demand to know
if rapper Snoop Dog is okay after he
announced he will stop smoking weed so
Snoop Dog posted saying quote I'm giving
up smoke he said after much
consideration and conversation with my
family I've decided to give up smoke
please respect my privacy at this time
so of course people are saying you know
a world Snoop without smoke is like
Earth without water of course other
people are saying that may maybe he's
launching a line of Edibles or Vapes
okay love that idea cuz he didn't say
I'm giving up weed even though I don't
think he talks like that but I think he
calls it smoke I think people you know
in the no call it that but it could be a
play on words because this is a
brilliant marketing move just absolutely
brilliant because I don't I think if
Snoop Dogg ever wanted to stop smoking
weed like go off King we love that um I
don't think he would share it honestly
because because it's such an integral
part of his brand and he's built you
know a real business off of being that
guy and let's say he did stop smoking I
think he would probably never tell us he
would just keep pretending you know
smoking tobacco or whatever like I I
don't I don't think he would actually
tell us I don't think this is like a a
transparent move I I do I I like that I
like that idea I think if he decided to
stop in part engaging with with the
smoke marijuana completely I think he
would tell people because I think he's
an authentic genuine guy I don't think
it's such an integral part of your brand
when you're I think for some people it's
like my brand is me whatever decisions I
make are on brand for me because that is
me and I think he is a a genuine Creator
I do no I love the call about Edibles
like but I think it's that she's giving
up smoke here are my
brownies yeah cuz this made waves
especially within the smoke Community
yeah most the last time you smoked pot
what a great question I'm going to
probably need your help maybe
like maybe during Co oh really once yeah
remember that one time we got
together I can't remember if I
participated though I know other people
were smoking where were
we I can't say oh cuz you don't remember
cuz you were high no I remember
everything I can't recall oh I think I
know I actually don't think I smoked
during Co cuz I was vaping more
so I can't remember last time I I feel
like maybe it was like even that
Coachella 2019 that's what I was going
to say or Stage Coach oh yeah then two
weeks later yeah we had a grand old time
but then I feel like I would have spoked
again because I had such a good time and
then I would have like had a bad been
like oh I don't want to spoke your last
time had to have been a bad time not bad
but just like enough for me to be like
this isn't for me yeah I think my last
time smoking pot maybe ever was Bon when
was that when did that clip go viral
three to four months ago I thought
you're going to say years no you just
say everything is 3 to four months maybe
like a year more than a year actually
cuz I know I was pretty fat In that clip
so yeah and that was the last time I
feel like you smoked recently no I don't
you're kind of always smoking really no
no I really don't like pot like at
all yeah me neither very paranoid it's
just not my person personality like if
I'm want to chill like I'll just go read
I don't know I I need no help in the
chill Department yeah that's how I feel
right like I would be more likely to
take like ecstasy cuz you know getting
up is hard for me you know getting it up
is hard for you getting it up yeah no
like I I need energy I don't need I I
need drugs for energy I don't need drugs
for like chilling yeah like if I have
the opportunity to chill I'm just going
to take it yeah no but if somebody wants
to go out all night like all right I'm
going to need someone to like crush up
an Aderall or something right I also
like don't need at this point in my life
like I don't want to be out of my own
mind yeah I mean you have children to
care for like that I understand no but
that's how I felt about drinking at a
certain point too
like like people drink to take the edge
off like I like my edges you know I
don't want to be blurry no I agree I I'm
like the just personality wise like the
opposite of someone who like wants or
needs pot like I don't know what to call
Pot every time we talk about pot
everybody makes fun of us like what do
people call it why don't we talk like
Snoop smoke
I'm just the opposite type of person the
way my brain is wired for smoke like I
agree I very much like to be in control
yeah yeah so EX for those few times why
did we enjoyed so much at stage coach
and Coachella well there's something
about being so far from home so it's
you're in the desert like you're so far
removed there's music there's drinks
there's lights there's Vibes like oh
actually I'm sorry actually you know
what that's a situation where like I
can't bring myself to chill out it's
very like high strung like it's actually
the perfect Vibe okay by the way I just
remember the last time I smoked pot was
at Stage Coach like somebody was passing
it around during Luke Bryan and I was
like if not now when and I had drank I
had drink all day this year I had drank
all day so I figured like it wouldn't
hit me that much and of course like I'm
watching Luke Bryan perform and I'm like
paranoid about it like it wasn't even
enjoyable that's the last time and
that's why I haven't smoked in a long
time cuz it wasn't enjoyable got it
those two times when we were in 2019
were hysteric
hysterical it also just depends like
where you are The Vibes it also depends
on the pot itself yeah no I would love I
would love to be the type of person who
like after a really [__] horrible day
like could just wind down with some pot
like how great would that be but I'll
just end up paranoid like sleep terribly
and eat a [__] ton but I if you're able
to wind down without pot then why would
you want to be the type of person no
like if I had a very hard stressful day
and like I can't unwind and like I'm
just feeling people feel anxious and
then smoke yeah I'm like no no I am I
smoke and then I feel anxious so when
you feel anxious what do you
do like complain take a bath papan no I
don't really um I just
drink in my hey I think maybe I was a
little bit more you know open to things
but everything makes me paranoid now
even the Xanax Friendly Fire I don't
take Xanax I haven't taken Xanax in
years and I miss it I
just I just I don't know why I don't
feel compelled but also you know I don't
want to jinx it I've had like a pretty
good you know like two years in terms of
like mental health so like I haven't
needed it that's good but I was
definitely taking Xanax a lot during Co
I mean who
wasn't totally oh that was a nice clear
of the throat and also I would have to
take Xanax more when I used to drink yes
same so I could sleep off The Hangover
yeah and the moral
hangover oh my God I like do you miss
it's a vicious cycle no I don't okay I'm
off the sauce we will be getting you
drunk one night on
vacation okay that's fine just bring the
S and we will take care of you the next
day we'll watch we'll watch the kids
like we'll do everything actually I was
going to say I haven't taken Xanax like
in years because I've either been
pregnant or or nursing but then Shantal
did tell me I could take Xanax while
breastfeeding don't tell me that but
also wouldn't want again I don't want to
be out of my own mind yeah yeah yeah
yeah so we'll see about that vacation
plan okay maybe some drinks okay our
fifth and final story is kind of a story
we've been waiting for for 10 years oh
wow yeah and today's the
day Ted the series is coming to Peacock
I saw this on your Instagram you broke
the news for you know who broke the news
for me who Cade posted it oh yeah yeah
for fans of the Ted movies a new series
focused on the events in the years
before the movies is coming to Peacock
early next year set in 1993 the Ted
series acts as a prequel to The Two
comedy movies featuring The titular
Talking Teddy Bear okay Ted prequel Seth
McFarland is a series director executive
producer writer and co- show it's 93 how
old is Ted and Mark Wahlberg Mark
Wahlberg is probably the age he was like
when he got 10 like so maybe like eight
oh oh oh so Mark Wahlberg's not in it
that's a good
point that's a good point yeah no I
guess he's going to be older because in
the movie A couple of years ago he's
yeah so let's say he's 35 now how old
were people in 1993 who are currently 35
oh wow Claudia you didn't tell me
there's going to be a pop quiz
today no totally I don't know uh but no
you're right he's not in the cast of
characters like his character is but not
I have a hot take like I don't think I
think that the franchise could go on
without Mark Wahlberg like I honestly
find him a little Annoying in the movies
I agree like Ted is the star and like
let's stop pretending he's not yeah no
it's all about Ted like this is not make
or break it's going to be a seven
episode series and I feel looks like I'm
signing up for peacock I feel very seen
I feel so happy that the franchise lives
on and I think as a society we have
failed Seth McFarland in not in not
bolstering and like boosting this
franchise into like it should be as big
as Marvel like
it's the most
brilliant well
done actually funny not haha it's
actually funny yeah and we I mean I'm
not talking about me because you and I
supported the [__] out of that franchise
but everyone else you guys failed comedy
you guys failed Ted you guys failed seic
and I think we collectively owe him an
apology that he's now having to do like
a seven episode series at peacock when
there should be should be a third
Blockbuster film with a Premiere as big
as Captain Marvel okay I agree that we
need Ted 3 it should be bigger than
Oppenheimer yeah like Ted is bigger than
Barbie to me Ted greater than than
Barbie but I don't feel like the movies
were not a success I think they were
very much a success it's just was so
long ago that we forgotten I actually
don't think they would be considered
like Gang Busters I think they would be
Gang
Busters let me look it upx I feel like
oh Ted grossed $218 million in North
America and $330 million overseas for a
gross of $550 against a budget of $50
million success let's check Ted
2 I can't I don't know if it would be
better or worse
I think it would be
worse
half so Ted grossed 80 million in North
America and 135 million in other
territories for a total of 216 million
and they had a bigger budget they had 68
million this time oh that's hard I
struggle with Ted
too
yeah because munas isn't in it and
because it's just like it wasn't great
enough it wasn't great enough
and I and I think munas not being in it
was a plot hole and Amanda sa freed like
wasn't the replacement for me wait
Amanda sea freed what was the plot of
Ted too like Ted's getting his rights
because um you know fresh cakes guy
wants to steal him honestly I don't even
remember Yik May the guy you know the
guy who wanted to kidnap Ted fresh cakes
fresh cakes of course
Dana he reminds me of D and by the way
he's also one of the people who signed
that letter for Danny Masterson Les we
not for forget fresh cakes fresh cakes
anyway so he goes to the CEO of Hasbro
and it's like you know Ted his property
we should be able to make a million like
I want we should be able to recreate Ted
let's get Ted back from John Bennett and
then Ted has to go to the Supreme Court
and Advocate like why he should have
rights and why he's not
property that's not great and like
Amanda sea freed is their
uh civil rights
lawyer okay yeah maybe maybe not but Ted
one is the greatest piece of art
literally of our time and I need to
watch it again wait I need to add it to
the list of movies yeah we need to
rewatch it's so
good it's so I went to New York once in
1981 and I just did not feel
safe we need Seth McFarland on the toes
I marri the wrong woman and now I lead a
life life of regret you know my voice
today sounds really good for that line
it does it does do it again I won't
interrupt you this time cool things I
married the wrong woman and now I lead a
life of regret no that scene is so funny
when he's like pretending to be all the
fish yeah what the fish are thinking
it's I went to New York once in 1981 and
I just did not feel safe so good so good
oh my God I'm joyous over this I will be
watching of course we should watch the
other SE McFarland show orille Family
Guy Family Guy yeah like that's the one
what are you talking about the
Orville oh yeah like
sci-fi it's
Seth do you think Seth McFarland's hot
yeah me too like I think he's really hot
but I think it's a combination of his
looks his inv insides influencing his
outsides yeah no and the influence he's
had on the culture wait but now I need
to look at a picture of him like
objectively like just like looking at
Eyes Nose
face
me
too by he literally like looks like his
characters do you know what I mean yeah
also are he kind of looks like Taylor
lner yeah he does every I think he's hot
he looks so different yeah I think he's
hot but I think definitely like his in
insides color his outsides and you love
that I mean everyone's insides color
their outsides it's true that's why I'm
so
[Laughter]
ugly um I've actually met Seth McFarland
I can't remember if he was nice I'm sure
he was I would have remembered if he was
like nasty so you wouldn't support him
all these years right no he was probably
lovely and you met Ted and I've met the
real Ted I have the bear she's seen the
bear I've seen the bear many times and
I've like I've G thought over it so many
times I keep hoping like it'll be given
to me as a gift you're like oh I know
how much it meant to you here take it do
you not think that on set they had like
multiple teds like they really only have
one bear no so I think that they have
multiple bears but I believe that the
bear that I came in contact with was the
bear used in the studio for
CGI like they didn't need a million in
the studio like Ted wasn't on set Jackie
CG
Yik you okay CGI right
right
right so that's our show that is our
show our final of the week hope
everybody enjoyed it and hope everybody
has a joyous blessed weekend filled with
holiday cheer and the amazing news is
that the next time we see you guys merch
will be available yes so it's shop toast
merch.com it'll be live at 10:00 a.m.
eastern time we are launching two
different sets they both come with
matching sweatpants Jackie's wearing the
wenie lights I am wearing the wenie
reindeer I am wearing a size medium for
a more fitted look but of course
oversized is still is still cool like I
could also do a large what size are you
wearing I'm wearing extra large it's too
big on me oh I'm I've never thought I'd
say those words about anything large if
I wanted oversized I should have gone
with large and keep in mind that it is
pre-order so it's not going to sell out
we're going to leave it up probably for
two whole days so everybody can place
their orders get everything they want in
terms of sizing and then we will close
the store and start producing the
sweatshirts and shipping out your orders
so also it's worth noting that these
sweatshirts and sweatpants are not are
not the same as any that we've made
before we have launched by the way we
have done a completely
complete revamp of our merch we have
moved companies we have moved vendors we
have moved everything so this is much
higher quality yeah so these sweatshirts
and sweatpants are not like comparable
to like a different set if it's not
going to be the same quality or fit like
these are far superior in my opinion and
I'm really excited for you guys to get
your hands on them yes so totally new
merch totally new everything we're
trying to keep the prices it's more
expensive stuff that we're using we are
trying to keep the prices as low as
possible but it will be more expensive
than our last draw yeah so just keep
that in mind um but the quality is there
and I it's like the coziest thing I wore
my wch T all day yesterday and I was
just in heaven me too and it's really
warm yeah that's our show you guys thank
you so much for listening to not not
that heavy thick again it's not
comparable anything else but when you
say really warm it's not the same as the
redheads one redheads are how you D
those were like a thick stock not thick
stock but it's th pretty thin but it's
not thin cuz thin would be like the
second redheads collection yeah yeah
yeah no it's not it's thicker than
that thank you guys so much for
listening to the toast of Millennium
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories he needs to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so
you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcast anywhere podcast can be found
Spotify public radio rast box all the
places podcast a beautiful Wily talented
we are I did all on my breath today she
still got it love you bye love you
bye